[Music]
early fishing lines were made of vines
and braided horsehair
but today fishermen rely on braided
synthetics to reel in their catch
with a higher tensile strength than
steel these lines are unlikely to snap
when they hook the big one
this fishing line may be thin but that
doesn't mean it's not strong
it's made of a synthetic called ultra
high molecular weight polyethylene
this same synthetic is used in milk jugs
water pipes
and even bulletproof vests
to make these fishing lines numerous
microfibers are braided into a single
tight cord
an employee starts by threading fibers
through needles
she pulls the needles through
spring-loaded devices
[Music]
the devices keep the fibers at an even
tension as they unwind onto small
[Music]
bobbins
these bobbins are designed to fit in the
braiding machines
[Music]
the machines are called maypole braiders
because the spools spin like dancers
around a maypole
[Music]
as they spin they weave the strands into
a tight braid
[Music]
there are 4 500 braiding machines in
operation at this factory
producing a tight braid is slow work
[Music]
it takes about 10 days to braid a 7 500
foot section of fishing line
[Music]
big spools overhead slowly revolve to
take up the braided polyethylene line
[Music]
at the same time a worker fills a metal
tank with hot water and adds yellow dye
to it
a pump at the bottom of the tank keeps
the water moving to evenly distribute
the dye
he stirs it a bit while he inspects the
mixing job
[Music]
they heat and pressurize the dye in a
tank filled with fishing line
the die penetrates all of the strands
for an even die job
these fishing lines go through a
different process
they unwind through metal eyelets into a
tray of yellow silicone resin
this proprietary resin makes the line
abrasion resistant
it will be less likely to break if
dragged across a surface like a rock
next the line travels through an oven to
cure the resin
it travels over a series of tensioning
rollers as it exits
then the line goes through an abrasive
eyelet which removes external
contaminants
finally it's rolled up by a spool
now it's over to a test station
[Music]
a technician clamps a piece of fishing
line in a testing apparatus
it pulls the fishing line from both ends
until it breaks
a gauge measures the line's breaking
point
[Music]
it snaps at 118 pounds of pressure
exceeding
requirements
[Music]
with the test piece of fishing line
approved
an automated system now transfers the
line to retail sized spools
[Music]
it loads about 450 feet of line onto
each one
a worker applies a label with product
details and packages it in a cardboard
box
[Music]
it takes about 17 days to braid color
and process a single spool
of synthetic fishing line
[Music]
strong but very thin it can be cast and
reeled in with ease
if the fish take the bait they may not
be able to get away
you